PhD student in computational
neuroscience and this year I'm gonna
attend a few scientific conferences
which wasn't really possible last year
due to Corona so I'm really excited and
also nervous and although I've already
attended one Conference during the
summer I thought this would be a good
opportunity to kind of give you some
tips and tricks of how I prepared for
these kind of conferences which you can
expect and also what you can do to
really prepare yourself as optimally as
possible so I know if this is your first
time attending a scientific conference
it can be quite daunting because all the
big names in the field will be present
but one thing I already want to say to
you is that it is really a learning
opportunity I think the amount of people
I've seen and the talks I've heard that
were really inspiring was really
surprising to me because of course you
can listen to talks online but I think
the ability to ask questions in real
life and have some discussions with
people people that really inspire you
it's just a really novel and exciting
experience but I want to give you four
tips on how to prepare for these kind of
events such that you have the best
mindset and the best toolkit to get the
most out of this event as possible so
the first thing that you want to do is
to research the conference in as much
detail as possible so look into the
conference schedule the keynote speakers
and other attendees this will give you
an idea of what to expect and allow you
to plan your schedule accordingly so for
example it could be that there is
usually double presentations at the same
time and maybe there is a particular
speaker that you want to listen but
another speaker that you like a lot as
well at the same time so you kind of
have to make a decision which
presentation you will attend and also
something that I would really recommend
is if there is poster session to look at
the type of posters that are being
presented in I've noticed that the
amount of information that I get from
posters and having discussions with the
people that created the posters is
actually a little bit more than what I
usually get at the big lectures so I
think a lot of people are focused on
these keynote speakers and these really
famous people but it's usually the
people working under them that actually
know a lot more about the specific topic
or the details in the topic that the big
keynote speakers are working on and
these people are always at the poster
sessions so they are presenting their
specific work on a poster so if you have
the ability to see the posters
beforehand I would definitely take a
look at all of them and kind of mark
down the poster numbers that you would
like to visit during the event so the
second tip that I would definitely give
is if you have the ability to present
anything to really take this ability so
if you're a novel researcher in a
certain field the chances of people
knowing your name are not too slim and
something that I didn't really realize
when I attended my first conference is
that people really like going to the
posters I'm talking to new researchers
but if you don't have your work on a
poster or you're not giving a small talk
you're kind of taking away the
possibility of other people to get to
know you and to get to know your work so
I actually really enjoyed presenting my
poster and having pretty in-depth
discussions with some other PhD students
postdocs or even professors about my
work and usually people that send your
poster are also really interested in the
topic or working on the topic themselves
so the first tip that I have is about
networking so I personally really hate
the word networking as it feels to me a
really contrived type of thinking where
you've really single out certain people
as being important enough for you to
network with but I had to change my
mindset about this a little bit because
I do think if you look up beforehand
which topics you're interested in and
which people you want to meet and you
just go from a heart of honest curiosity
I think it's fine to approach people a
little bit that are working in the same
topic as you and also something that I
want to emphasize in this part is not to
only go towards the keynote speakers or
the most important or famous professors
because actually in 10 years when you're
gonna be at that position maybe these
are not gonna be your colleagues your
colleagues are actually going to be the
PhD students that are working under them
so something that I would do actually is
to also really meet the PhD students of
these famous professors because a lot of
times what I have noticed is that some
of these really famous lecturers are
actually not as nice as they seem and
PhD students are actually way more open
about their research they are doing and
also usually a lot more humble so some
professors of course are super nice and
attentive but the chances of you having
a successful collaboration opportunity
or getting a really interesting
Connection in my opinion usually lies a
little bit more with the PhD students
and the postdocs and the last tip that I
have offer you is to practice your pitch
so a lot of people will ask you at the
conference what are you working on and
usually you have about one minute to
tell them what you're working on so I
would prepare a little bit different
pitches of your research so of course
some of us have really clear research
goals like I want to solve depression in
2023 but some of us have actually really
difficult topics that are quite hard to
explain in one minute but it is really a
skill and something you need to develop
to be able to explain this in one minute
on different levels such that when
someone that you're really interested in
is asking you what are you actually
working on that you have a good clear
answer so yeah these were just some tips
on how I would prepare for a large
conference if you are attending a
conference this summer or this year I
would love to know so please put it down
in the comments below where you're going
and who you're meeting over there and
otherwise see you next week bye